the Mighty Ducks might never have made
it to the screen if it weren't for Wayne
Gretzky's trade to the LA Kings in 1988
a move that sparked an increased
interest in ice hockey throughout Los
Angeles and didn't go unnoticed by
Hollywood execs Steven Brill script
about a down-and-out lawyer taking over
a useless peewee team was picked up by
Disney and the mouse house quickly set
about preparing sequels after the
box-office success of the 1992 original
coach Gordon Bombay and his ragtag
roster of players triple deke - their
way into pop culture history Ducks never
saved I never seen a duck fight no way
why but you can't play peewee forever
and Bombay's ducklings are now all grown
up and not all of them found Hollywood
success after leaving the nest Emilio
Estevez the role of Gordon Bombay
allowed Emilio Estevez to shake off the
brat pack tag he carried throughout the
80s he'd already attempted to move away
from coming-of-age drama DS with his
turn as Billy the Kid in the young guns
movies though Bombay was his first real
grown-up character he carried on acting
into the late 90s and early 2000s but
now spends much of his time writing and
directing he still holds Gordon Bombay
close to his heart however which he
proved in 2015 when he live tweeted
support for the Anaheim Ducks during
their playoff showdown with the Chicago
Blackhawks Joshua Jackson the part of
championship winning penalty scorer
Charlie Conway was originally supposed
to be played by a young Jake Gyllenhaal
who was offered the part on the back of
his performance as Billy Crystal's son
in 1991 city slickers Joshua Jackson
stepped in when Jake couldn't take it
which kick-started a career that's grown
to include five season stints on
Dawson's Creek and fringe Jackson made
his transition from movies to TV after
taking his final vow as Charlie in 1996
as Mighty Ducks threequel d-3 and he
remains a man of the small screen today
starring in showtimes the affair Elden
Henson it's hard to believe Matt
Murdock's lovable sidekick foggy Nelson
is the same guy that played hulking
enforcer Fulton Reed Elden Henson made
his first appearance in The Mighty Ducks
when members of the team were
cornered by players from their rival
team the Hawks dispatching the bullies
with ease
Henson went on to be a key member of the
team and the cast over the course of the
three movies but when the Ducks
disbanded he struggled to make an impact
in the showbiz industry resorting to
supporting parts in such films as the
butterfly effect
Henson's fortunes have taken a turn for
the better over recent years not only on
the big screen when he played the part
of Pollux in the two-part Hunger Games
finale but on television too he's
portrayed well-meaning lawyer foggy and
Netflix's daredevil
as well as in the team-up series the
defenders Shawn Weiss before making his
film debut in the Mighty Ducks Shawn
Weiss worked on several TV shows
including an early appearance on The
Cosby Show by 1992 he'd grown into a
big-boned fourteen-year-old and was
considered a perfect fit for the role of
goalie Greg Goldberg
he went on to portray the flatulent
goalie in the duck sequels taking time
off between them to star in an early Ben
Stiller comedy heavyweights a film that
went on to a massive cult following of
its own Weiss saw the 90s out with a
four Episode stint on Judd Apatow as
freaks and geeks though the next decade
wasn't kind to him with his most
significant appearance in a feature film
coming as the unnamed bus driver in 2008
drillbit Taylor Matt Doherty after
taking the part of Lester averman in the
Mighty Ducks movies Matt Doherty got
another 90s classic on his resume and so
I married an ax murderer as he
approached the dolt hood rolls started
to dry up for Doherty and he walked the
tightrope between Supporting Actor and
extra in recent years he's turned to TV
movies and found some success on the
sci-fi small-screen scene Garret Henson
this young star got off to a flying
start with his movie career appearing in
ten feature films over a six-year period
he made his bow in arachnophobia for
example but Garret Henson is perhaps
best remembered as a Jermaine from The
Mighty Ducks movies while he admits to
enjoying a chat about the Ducks today
being associated with the film started
to wear thin towards the end of the
decade he ultimately stepped away from
acting to pursue college and made a
brief return to the biz in 2007 when he
played a prisoner in the Mansfield 12
he's now busy working behind the lens
danny tamborelli italian-american actor
and musician danny tamborelli played the
role of defenseman tommy duncan in the
Mighty Ducks though he didn't return for
either of the sequels instead tamborelli
opted to take on the role of little Pete
Wrigley in Nickelodeon's The Adventures
of Pete and Pete the role that he's
still best remembered for the kids
Network added him to the cast of their
slimey gameshow figure it out and their
live sketch comedy all that in the late
90s though he departed from Nickelodeon
at the turn of the millennium and
transitioned into voice work music and
comedy nowadays tamborelli fronts
Brooklyn based rock band counts Jesse
Smollett Justin Jesse Smollett recently
pulled off a comeback worthy of the
Mighty Ducks turning his fading career
around and putting himself firmly back
on the Hollywood map Smollett appeared
in the first Ducks
b-but didn't reprise the role of Terry
Hall in either sequel and it wasn't
until the 2010s when he landed a
career-making role in Fox's hit series
empire that things got back on track
thanks to his compelling work on the
celebrated series Ridley Scott cast him
in his prometheus sequel alien covenant
and he's well on his way to the top
Vincent Larusso when we first meet Adam
banks in the Mighty Ducks he's the star
player for the Ducks rival team who had
to change squads due to his fudged home
address he was an unlikely hero for the
Ducks in the end and Vincent Larusso
portrayed banks in all three Mighty
Ducks movies Larusso made a brief and
unexpected return to the big screen when
he portrayed the bank robber in the 2008
spoof superhero movie though that
remains his last credit of any notes
today the former Duck works as an
inventory controller for the hospitality
chain Soho House Brandon Adams otherwise
known as Jesse Hall in the first two
Mighty Ducks movies Brandon Adams was
exposed to the world of acting as a
toddler when he appeared in a number of
commercials but his big break came when
he was cast as Zeke baby bad Michael in
Michael Jackson's Moonwalker he went on
to work with Wes Craven in the people
under the stairs before nabbing The
Mighty Ducks role Adam always had one
foot in film while the other remained in
television however and he started to
lean more heavily on the ladder as his
career progressed he has some genuine
90s classics to his name including the
Sandlot Marguerite Moreau
as Connie in The Mighty Ducks Marguerite
Moreau may have inspired a lot of young
girls to break down gender norms and hit
the ice
the actress seemed to grow up pretty
quickly after the Mighty Ducks trilogy
ended in 1996 appearing as camp
counselor Katie and wet hot American
summer a short five years later a major
role in Queen of the Damned followed
soon after but while she continued to
make regular movie appearances
throughout the 2000s the part she was
offered became increasingly on
fulfilling and she turned her attention
to television Moreau has plied her trade
in small screen classics such as
Smallville Parenthood and Mad Men and
also reprised the role of Katie in 2015
when she reunited with her wet hot
American summer cast mates for Netflix's
prequel series first day of camp
Jadey Daniels even though he was a
prolific child actor in the 1990s JD
Daniels did not come back to reprise the
role of Peter mark and either of the
Mighty Ducks sequels and instead went on
to win a number of new roles across a
variety of genres like some of his Ducks
colleagues Daniels moved into voiceover
work and although he hasn't notched up
an acting credit in almost a decade
Daniels remains active in the industry
currently working for the Actors Equity
Association Aaron Schwartz practically
unrecognizable today the broad and
bearded Aaron Schwartz has come a long
way since playing chubby prankster Dave
Karp in the first Mighty Ducks he joined
up with fellow duck Danny tamborelli for
an eight-episode stint on The Adventures
of Pete and Pete then teamed up with
another former castmates Shawn Weiss for
Judd Apatow's heavyweights when the
formerly heavyset Schwartz reappeared
after a 15-year absence from the
industry in the CW's Gossip Girl he'd
grown into a primetime worthy hunk he'll
join the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
2017 when he takes on the role of young
ego in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 a
younger version of Kurt Russell's
character and just when you think
they're about to break apart thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to